hi everyone today I'm at the beautiful
University of Sydney and I'm here with
Siobhan Tobin hi and today we're going
to be talking about this exam which is
the international physics Olympiad this
is the exam from 2016 and Ivan vited
Chiron along because she is quite the
expert in these particular exams so this
is a basically Olympics for physics
students yeah so it's the Olympics for
high school students around the world
you're interested in fashion about
science yeah and so you've done this
before I haven't and you were also a
team leader in 2016 so we're going to
have a little bit of a look through this
paper see what it's all about
it does say that it's made of two parts
there's an experimental and a
theoretical part it says that there five
hours each is that 10 hours in a row so
how does that work okay thank goodness
it's five hours on one day which is the
experiment and then the students have a
day off and then they come back on the
day after that for the theory paper
which is another five hours okay but
each five hour exam is yeah five hours
without stopping that sounds quite
intense so let's have a little look at
what's in here alright so here is the
exam we'll just flick through and have a
look at some of the questions this is a
bit of the preamble so this is the first
part of the example the first exam which
is experimental so it looks like they're
just showing us pictures of everything
we've got available to use so I imagine
we're doing this in a room where we've
actually got all these available to us
as well yeah all the equipment for the
experiments would be on your desk so
okay so yet more preamble and
introduction to resistance in
resistivity so the experimental exam is
divided into two parts and this part is
about the sheet resistance of different
two-dimensional shapes and different
materials so the materials you're given
a silicon wafer and some graphite paper
all right it seems quite nice of them to
give us so much preamble
at least we can get an idea of what's
happening and here's where it looks like
the question actually starts for the
experimental part so you're being
introduced to this kind of 4 point probe
measurement where you've got something
that basically you can find out
different values of voltage and current
through a kind of a circuit that you're
making on your silicon wafer or your
graphite paper this is a little bit more
theory I think just explaining some
concepts about different kinds of shapes
and how the geometry of your material
can affect resistance and resistivity so
it looks like they sort of lead us
through each step of the experiment that
they want us to do do you think that if
you didn't quite get a part of the
experiment earlier that you can do the
later part so how it works yes certainly
movie moving through different parts of
the experiment even if you're unsure of
earlier parts is a great technique part
of the physics Olympiad is that you have
to analyze your results within the time
frame as well so it's not like you can
take your results away and have a think
about them you've got to plot them in
the exam and draw some conclusions at
the same time so we've got like
questions that say explicitly to plot
the data and the measurements you've
take is that all done by hand
probably about yeah it is so you have to
be pretty accurate with your graph paper
and this is the last page for this
particular experiment and I'm sort of
impressed about how many different steps
have actually been involved in this I
can sort of see why it takes so long now
this is the second experiment and he
looks quite interesting so this is
something to do with jumping beads and
they're using like poppy seeds on a
material to measure phase transitions
which sounds like a very abstract way to
do this so this question is pretty
interesting like poppy seeds what's that
got to do physics so they had this neat
little setup with a loudspeaker that
bounces up and down and then you put
your seeds into a container on top of
that loudspeaker and the container is
split into two and your task is
basically to watch how the poppy seeds
jump from one side of the container to
the other while the loudspeakers going
up and down so that models the phase
transition which yeah that's pretty
impressive
so here you've got this little diagram
which kind of conceptualizes the physics
so these arrows are pointing the same
way that's representing the phase where
all the poppy seeds just stay on one
side of the container and then if you
turn your loudspeaker up enough then all
the poppy seeds start jumping around
between the two sides of the container
and that that's a phase transition so
and you're looking for that critical
point where it's about 50/50 yeah where
all of a sudden you reach this kind of
steady state where you've got the same
number of poppy seeds in each side
because they're just jumping back and
forth all the time and this idea is kind
of linked to it a temperature in the
explanation here so it is pretty
abstract okay so we'll just briefly
flick through the rest of this poppy
seed experiment and we'll get on to the
theoretical side thank you so we've now
arrived at the theory half of the exam
we've got some nice little constants
here so thank you for providing those
mr. exam and it looks like we're
starting off with a problem out about
mechanics yeah in this question it's
split into two parts but both parts are
mechanics questions testing your
knowledge of rotational dynamics and
things like moments of inertia and and
stuff that's in the physics Olympiad
syllabus yeah so they've given us like
this set up here and then on the next
page
they modify it a bit and then ask us
basically every question I can sort of
imagine about rotational mechanics in a
way and everything you need to know
about that they're basically asking you
yeah so in this part here you're really
looking at things like balancing talks
and balancing forces you've got this
desk that's got a heavier disk somewhere
inside it and the point of the question
is to figure out where the heavier desk
is so you roll your kind of compound
just down a slope and see what position
it stops and then here you use it as a
kind of pendulum and and then there are
a whole bunch of questions about the
periods of oscillation and moments of
inertia and centers of mass oh that's
good good mechanic stuff yep and then
this second part
it's about rotating Space Station and
how that mimics like gravity basically
so how they do all these sort of
experiments with a spring to see how a
spring that's on this rotating Space
Station how that does it act any
differently from a spring that you're
holding and bouncing up and down on
earth and that kind of thing so it's
like gravity to what extent do you think
all these mechanics questions here rely
on formulas and memorizing formulas do
you think that will get you part of the
way they've certainly given you a few
formulas throughout the exam but knowing
how to use them and employ techniques
such as dimensional analysis is also
important because you're required to
sort of work with the formulas to create
your own equations okay this is ending
the mechanics section it looks like and
we're getting into sort of electricity
now this question here was quite
interesting this is voltage versus
current but it doesn't look anything
like the usual voltage versus current
thoughts that we would see at school
you'll often see a
current-voltage plot that might be a
straight line and that's your kind of
standard resistor but here it's not just
a straight line it's a kind of zigzag
things so it's quite a nonlinear
electronic device the fact it has this
zigzag so in this question you're asked
to investigate different properties of
these nonlinear electric devices that
impresses me quite a lot because if I
try to remember back to high school and
the age I was when this paper would be
relevant like I was only doing really
straight Ohm's law type stuff I would
just have straight lines here and I feel
like I was never really learning about
non ohmic things and to like university
and it's my university courses so yeah
that impresses me to know this so early
but even for a university student this
is kind of a puzzling situation because
it's not just a nice function
you've got points here where the device
can jump between different states and
you can even kind of set up a cycle
where it can move around this curve
including jumps so it's quite an unusual
thing and certainly I hadn't seen
something like it until this exam I can
actually use Ohm's law in parts of this
question to obtain values for
resistances depending on the state the
device is in so it all helps all right
and then very relevant for this exam
which was held in Zurich and Switzerland
ooh we have a question all about the
Large Hadron Collider so it looks like
this part of the question is a bit of an
intro and then it's all going to be kind
of about particle physics and some more
modern physics I guess to the previous
questions and this question also uses a
lot of concepts from relativity yeah I
just saw a gamma here yeah yeah cuz of
course the protons are moving really
really fast around the Large Hadron
Collider yeah so again that I think was
something I didn't see until maybe first
year and onwards that uni was actually
relativistic considerations and in the
very last part of this question you're
looking at how different kinds of
particles
how they move between detectives and how
you can use that information to identify
which particles you've got like the
charge and the mass of different
particles that's more of the particle
identification question and that looks
like it's actually our last page as well
with just a little question over the end
there so that was I think a bit of a
beast of an exam yeah it's a pretty mega
exhibit down we'll keep in mind that
that is two exams it's the experimental
and the theoretical but yeah it would
really take a lot of actually practice
just to be able to work for five hours
at a time
do you get like a break or anything in
those five hours and of course you can
even go the toilet all right so this
exam if you guys are curious I've just
downloaded from the website which I'll
link down in the description so you
don't need to pause the video and squint
to see the figures you can have a look
at the full PDF and there's a few other
exams on there as well me and Sherwin
have filmed another video talking more
in detail about the Olympian in terms of
what it is and some tips and tricks if
you're studying for it so check that
video out after the Sun and thanks for
watching
you